mission accomplished really since the
war on terror began in 2001 the US has
claimed to have successfully captured
and killed hundreds of so-called
terrorists this narrative dominates much
of what we watch read and hear but at
what cost
targeted airstrikes long-term detention
without trial countries in chaos out
there and the erosion of civil liberties
at home you know the very freedoms the
terrorists are supposed to hate
dictators have been toppled but weren't
they once allies moderate extremists
seven armed to fight extreme dictators
moderate dictators armed to fight
extreme extremists how on earth do you
fight a war on terror anyway is terror
an idea does it have a geography 13
years on has the war on terror been a
failure tell us what you think subscribe
on YouTube follow us on Twitter and like
us on Facebook